thank you president
um some sad news this week we lost
former assemblyman former speaker Pro
tem of the assembly Dr Paul Aisley he
was a mathematician I first met him at
UNLV when I was an undergrad he was a
director of summer programs and he was
trying to help me graduate and not drop
out and he was wonderful back then and I
never thought I'd I'd serve with him in
the state legislature as a state
legislator he was a Pioneer in the area
of equality for the transgender
Community he sponsored a bill in 2009
that would have prohibited
discrimination for the transgender
Community it was referred to committee
never got a hearing he tried again in
2011 that bill was passed in the law and
it was the first Statute in Nevada I
believe to prohibit discrimination
against the transgender Community he
tried to Champion a lot of causes that
weren't popular and didn't have a lot of
other folks who would try to Champion
those causes and he he tried his best
sponsoring legislation requiring
labeling for food that contained GMOs
and genetically modified organisms
that didn't pass but he he fought hard
for that one he uh
I fought hard incentives with motion
picture and picture industry
very devoted to UNLV if you ever saw his
car he had the personalized license
plate UNLV that he drove around in and
just somebody who cared a lot about the
state and we lost him this week